what if our world wasn't the only one
where existence is absurd please refer
to the danger menu for tips on how not
to die if your seed is in the Peril row
you must help us take the machine apart
your reward is more legroom
Jitter liquid please would you like to
Jitter for one two or five hours
describe your current level of activity
[Music]
average give me that mild poison
I'll let you two talk while I go over
here and pretend not to listen ah irony
is that irony I'm never sure
this is the adventure we live for
tiny trash
the bad moments will pass even the good
moments will pass that's what our
existence is all about
wow you licked me inside the mouth this
is disgusting and it's perfect
[Music]